oh
[Musique]
les consignes c'est de ne pas chasser
la côte du sud
est
[Musique]
tout d'abord on peut pas se permettre de
compromettre la sécurité de l'auteur du
rodéo qui forcément va partir
à prendre des risques il va prendre des
risques pour lui-même et aussi pour les
usagers de la route
et les collègues également vont prendre
des risques
de même pour
21 10
on
je veux dire ma totale désapprobation et
ma grande fermeté devant ce phénomène
que je qualifie de criminel il ya eu
depuis deux mois à 8000 opération par la
police et de la gendarmerie elle a fait
naître 1200 aux interpellations c'est du
jamais vu je souhaite qu'ils aient dix
mille opérations de contrôle à partir
d'aujourd'hui partout sur le territoire
national pour lutter contre ces actes
criminels aux gens qui prennent la route
pour leur route
[Musique]